well most of us wake every morning
wondering what the world holds for us
today
our teachers wake every morning asking
what the world holds for our children
and spend the day preparing them before
that future and that is why it is said
that teaching is one of the most noble
professions in the world the global
teacher prize is a beautiful idea for it
celebrates the tireless work that
teachers do every day across the world
we are very proud that a Kenyan teacher
Michael Ramaiah has reached the final
ten for this year's prize through dance
he inspires young people to be the best
they can be and Kenya as a whole is
proud of you for this effort I would
also like to extend a huge thank you to
His Highness Sheikh Mohammed bin Rashid
Al Maktoum for his support to the
teaching profession and his patronage of
this price we thank you for your efforts
for our children's future I would also
thank and congratulate the Varkey
foundation for giving us such a
wonderful and powerful celebration of
the work that teachers do and your
commitment to education throughout the
world
our Kenyans are rooting for our teacher
to win this year's prize that is not
forget today that the ultimate winner is
every single teacher across the globe
who sacrifices his life and time for our
children's future
I thank you